hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
welcome to another winners on a
wednesday
every single week i help somebody become
financially free and this week i want to
introduce you to jamal robinson he's 21
years
old he is financially free and he's here
to share the story of exactly what he
did and how you can do the same thing
too
so jamal welcome to winners on a
wednesday bro thank you for having me
such a such a pleasure to be here
now some people might remember you
because you were the very first person
that got evicted
very first quite unfortunate but um
that's how it worked out and
everything's worked out since then
anyway you had literally the shortest
amount of airtime ever on the show but
you said you still got business from it
yeah
yeah it was crazy like as soon as i
started putting videos on social media
and stuff people
already recognizing me and even asking
me for advice and stuff even though
you're like
i got a victory don't ask me but still
the fact that
yeah yeah hundreds of people applied to
be on the show but you got there
um since you've gone on to do training
you've done the um brr
training you've done rent to rent
training and um
now you've got multiple deals
and and you're financially free so tell
us how it happened
yeah so um a bit about me and my
background um
i didn't really grow up with much my
dad's always been in property
but my mum and dad separated when i was
about one years old
so i was never around him much um i grew
up on a counsellor's day
went to a bad school and stuff and then
pretty much through school i've always
had like an entrepreneurial mind
and i've always known that i'm gonna do
like something with my life have a
business
something like that yeah something
similar to my dad but probably not the
same thing i was never
i never thought about property um i was
always selling sweets and stuff you know
like in school making my
making my own spending money did you
have a paper round and i didn't have a
paper on but
me and my friend we used to like control
the whole supply
of our year for the sweets oh yeah yeah
make like a sweet deal
yeah yeah i don't even have paper a
thing anymore but i know most people
most people like you and like our
natural entrepreneurs had like a paper
and a hustled at school
yeah yeah always hustling did you do
well in school
i did i did all right to be fair um
and then when i went on to a levels i
was doing it and i was just i went
i wasn't really enjoying it i got offers
from four
different universities but i just
decided i'm just not going to go to
university at all
i saved up a few thousand pounds um
for some reason i'm not even sure why i
probably should have but i actually
didn't
finish any of my a-level exams yeah i
spent three years doing it but i just
didn't finish i just dropped out
completely interesting so you dropped
out
you dropped out of school yeah yeah you
didn't go to uni yeah
um what did what did your mom think
about that
so i don't know she didn't really know
at the time that i dropped out i was i
wasn't really going and she didn't
really know at the time
um but i told him i wasn't going to uni
and i started a business around the same
time
so she was happy about that and it was
doing well so i started a clothing brand
um in sheffield and literally it did way
better than i expected
like straight away it was doing good and
i knew a lot of people in sheffield so
like word of mouth
i was getting friends to wear it it was
growing on instagram
literally of everyone i knew in
sheffield um it was like the most
it was like the fastest growing
instagram page getting the most
engagement wow
thousands of likes all of this we
released one we did one release
sold out did another release a few
months later sold out straight away yeah
um and then a bit further down the line
on the business side of things there was
a lot of complications with like
suppliers and stuff
the supplier that we actually had went
bust and
i didn't have no like plan b or anything
like that and then pretty much just went
like
all hectic from there yeah and didn't
really know what to do i didn't really
have any business experience
but i was just going through with it and
it was working prior but
it was pretty much going downhill from
there and it was losing momentum and
stuff
yeah so what i was doing because i
wasn't a uni
i didn't have a job but that's what i
was doing full-time that business
but what we did is it took about six
months of ordering samples because if
anyone knows like the clothing industry
making a brand it's like there's a lot
of complications when it comes to stuff
like that like ordering samples
uh supply and demand and stuff yeah um
so we ended up ordering a massive
amount when the demand was low and spent
basically half my savings and didn't
really get any sales as well
so it was pretty much like what's going
on so you put your all into it it was
like there was a
big momentum yeah and then people when
people wanting it
i couldn't provide it anymore because
the supplier went i was having all these
problems
and then by the time i did have it i
bought too much and no one wanted it
anymore
yeah and it was like that and um so i
was
i was still pushing it and i was still
trying to to like grind with it
and i was doing jobs on the side i
worked at security
i even worked at a pretty little thing
warehouse and one of the main reasons i
worked there was one
i wanted to find and meet the owner and
speak to him and actually did us all
and two i wanted to on the boxes that
they received i wanted to find out who
their suppliers were
and like what companies they were
working with and stuff so i could try
and contact them and stuff like that
yeah nice so you're like
you're like a smart natural born
entrepreneur
yeah yeah and people say to me are
entrepreneurs born
or are they made and i think the answer
is both i think yeah
if you're a born entrepreneur but you're
not made and you don't have training
then you're gonna have the fire and
you're gonna be doing stuff and hustling
but maybe not quite making the money you
need to be making
you know if that's it you're not born an
entrepreneur but you're
made and you go through training you
might not have the inclination
or the fire to keep going when it gets
tough so
say you're a born entrepreneur how did
you come across me and my training and
what
yeah so so that was pretty much um close
after that
so after doing those jobs i realized um
i didn't like it or like well i was
working 12-hour shifts
pretty little thing warehouse and i
hated it to be honest
and i just left and that was around my
19th birthday
and i was thinking how else am i going
to get money so i thought i'm just going
to have to
at this point i didn't really have a
relationship with my dad i did as a kid
but as i grew up
we kind of like distanced i'm not sure
why but um
for that year i probably saw him only
once or twice in the whole year
but i thought i'm i'm probably gonna
have to approach my dad and start
working for him
and then learn about the property and
what does he do he's got like a
he's got a state agency so he's been in
it for about 20 years
cool so he's long in the game yeah yeah
yeah yeah a state agent in sheffield
yeah established yeah so what happened
you went and got a job so
yeah so i put on my 19th birthday i told
him i want to start working
for him so i started working for him and
a few months in i was already doing
viewings i was learning a lot i was
supervising other staff even i was going
out i was bringing in landlords
doing inspections renting out properties
everything and then that's when i
realized like
there's a lot of money to be made in
property i was meeting landlords that
were making
crazy amounts they were collecting rents
from like 20 properties at a time
and at the time i thought the only way
in property is to have a lot of money
dump it in one save up again dump it in
another
i don't know about all these creative
ways but i knew there was like a way for
me to make it
so i started researching online looking
at different videos and stuff on youtube
and i was looking at all these different
guys
but this is before i even discovered
yourself and
i was watching it and it was pretty much
just like a like a uni seminar or
something
someone stood with a whiteboard just
with a boring voice just going through
and it's pretty boring
and i came across yourself and your
videos were actually like fun to watch
and that's something that like properly
separated you from everyone else
and i was watching your videos like
actually enjoying them and learning at
the same time
yeah so i kept doing that and i just
kept watching your videos all the time
and even whilst at work um carried on
working there was
i was very busy there doing a lot so i
wasn't really like taking action on
these strategies
um and then shortly after your
crash course came about and this was 20
2019 in birmingham so i was like yeah i
have to go i was like one
one pound for a course from this guy i
have to go i can't not go
and i drive so i drove straight there
went for the the two days
amazing course and that was the first
time i was in an actual networking event
so that was the first time i was ever
like around everyone that's on the same
mission
everyone energy so high and stuff it was
like it was crazy man like
and when you when you're working as an
estate agent i mean it's quite different
to being
a property investor entrepreneur like
what we do now um
what what what were you what was your
salary how much were you on so i was on
200 pounds a week i was like i was
earning 400 pounds a week at the
pretty little thing but um interesting
so you took a back step so i was like
half
half a cutting pay but then you knew
that you were in the right industry now
yeah and i sort of knew like this is a
business i can just help grow the
business yes
if i actually if i need anything my dad
will probably be able to provide for me
but that's a good lesson in that yeah
it's a good lesson
because you're working 400 pound a month
sorry 40 percent a week to put it i
think
which is okay like 1600 pound a month
cool
you then took a half pay cut half
but it's one step back to then step
forward
and why i knew the right industry what i
knew is i needed to
i needed to learn and value my learning
and progress more than more than money
yeah and i know i know i'm young
and i've got time so i just need to
learn skills and value that more than
the amount i'm earning yeah well you
know what that's what i was doing poor
people trade their time for money yeah
rich people trade their time for
knowledge yeah so that's what you were
doing yeah you love i think you learned
loads
of auburn stuff i read i read your book
by then
um great book probably the best poppy
book i've read thanks man um
and because there's other property books
but a lot of them are like american
versions and for uk investing like by
far it's the best thing i've read yeah
and
from that i learned that you you started
off pretty much working for nothing
and just just giving value and just
giving a story similar story to you
exactly exactly so that's
exactly why i fouled in school yeah
parents separated yeah
i had nothing it was working for my dad
but on a very low income
yeah um and then it's just a similar
story so talk to me then through
i mean you came to the property
investors crash course what happened
then yeah so after the crash course
um i knew about all these strategies and
i was still
i was still very busy at the estate
agency and i was thinking yeah i'm gonna
plan to one day get a service
accommodation or something
and then one one day i got a call from
some guys at the office
and they said oh um we've got a property
we've got hmo
before i didn't know what hmo was but
then i knew what it was
they were like we've got hmo um would
you guys be able to manage it so i was
like yeah sure
i'll come to the property we'll have a
look uh we'll talk about it
so we went there it was actually in
sheffield i know
all the ins and outs of sheffield
and all the ins and outs of sheffield i
knew that this was quite a bad area and
they wanted it as a hmo for our students
and what actually was was it was a count
on a council block in a bad area
it was a three-bedroom masonette and
they turned the living room into
the fourth bedroom so it's a
four-bedroom council mason there in a
bad area bad condition
no living room one small bathroom and i
knew already like this
isn't like a suitable hmo but i thought
we'll do what we can
i sat down with the guys that's what
we'll do what we can we'll take viewings
and we'll see if we can get it let out
for you
and we did about 10 15 viewings no one
wanted it
there was probably one serious guy so i
called back the guys and they they were
doing it on a rent-to-rent basis as well
so they were doing a rent-to-rent deal
please then yeah so they were doing a
rental rent deal and they thought we've
got this html
we'll make four bedrooms living room and
then they gave it to us
to manage um i was like it's not really
going to work but what you can try
is service accommodation and they also
knew about us all but they didn't think
about
doing that yeah and it's i learned that
from you and
from your videos so i suggested that to
them i said look you can
even you can keep the bed in the living
room just put a sofa in there put a tv
in there make it look like a nice little
living room spice the place up a bit put
it on booking.com airbnb in that
and then that's what they did that she
took my advice and
i knew that the estate agency aren't
going to benefit from this because we're
not going to be taking cuts because we
won't be managing it yeah but what i was
just trying to do is just give value to
these guys
yeah and that's what i did and they did
that and they started making
500 pounds plus every month from that
and then a couple months later i got a
call from them
not the office but to my actual phone
they called me and they were like listen
we're in birmingham we're from
birmingham we're doing deals here
and we've got that deal in sheffield but
it's a bit of too much hassle for us so
do you want it
so that was how i got the first name
advice yeah so it was like
i just gave value to them yeah and i
didn't expect anything in return and it
just came back to me anyway and your
knowledge that's the thing if you want
to be able to add
people say how can i add value how can i
add value well get knowledge
yeah because your knowledge suddenly
meant that you could start being
valuable to people which resulted in you
having a deal
yeah so you're making what like 500
pounds a month off that yeah yeah so um
obviously at the time i didn't i didn't
really know about um
about sourcing fees and stuff yeah so
they were like yeah so we want um 3 000
for it
so i was like wait a minute i don't have
3 000. so it took me like a week back
and forth with him
managed to negotiate to uh 1.8 000 okay
and then we took it on and then that was
the first one and then my dad and then
my dad started to realize i was actually
making money from this
and i told him because they came to the
office we exchanged contracts
and we met with the landlord and stuff
we were paying 690 per month for this
and we were generating about 2 000
pounds yeah um
so my dad realized that this is a actual
viable business that we can start up so
we started up a new business
i told him all about what i'd learned
from yourself as well with service
accommodation
and literally within two weeks from the
connections that he already has
he managed to get 10 more units nice 10
more units but
because he's so busy in the estate
agency is handling about
150 grand a month in rents he's busy
handling that so he was like
yeah i've got these units so just manage
the business and do that
so pretty much it was straight from i
was doing this agency two months
experience
to i'm doing this agency and now i'm
managing the sa business with living
units
at this point now at this point now i
think this is when you came around my
house
uh yeah i came around your house a bit
further on okay
so what happened then absolutely so what
happened was um i came around your house
was that um that was after lockdown
wasn't it yeah it was drawing a lot of
things
yeah yeah so what happened was we had
these 11
um and from then we were making about
five six grand a month
profit from them and then at the end of
the year we actually managed to get
another deal
a million pound property from another
landlord
and that was five luxury apartments and
my dad decided to move into one of them
as well
so he's living rent-free there and plus
we're making an extra
i think it's about 700 pounds a month
from them no and that was a hmo so i
didn't have to actively manage that
yeah just passive income and he was
living right three and then
after that everything's going well we
had plans for
uh 2020 to like expand go further
and then all of a sudden coronavirus
came and then it was pretty much just
like
what do we do now yeah and i was looking
on my phone and by april time
every single day or thousands of pounds
of bookings just getting cancelled
council cancelled the
notifications coming up and we managed
to negotiate with the landlords and
like just to stay afloat and just keep
everything under control we didn't take
any bookings
i didn't even think about contractors
and stuff
and i pretty much just stopped working
all together by by then in the lockdown
and then i was just in the lockdown i
had a bit of money i had i had a car i
was living in one of the apartments and
stuff
but i just wasn't doing anything and at
this time because i was so busy with the
with the service accommodation before
i'd stopped watching your videos and
stuff
and i just thought i've got it figured
out i'm just going to keep going this
business but by then
in lockdown i just didn't really know
what i was doing what do you think the
lesson is in there
the lesson is just to just to keep
learning always and
try and get around people and because
all of my friends at the time
they all saw me as like oh jamal he's
he's got properties he's got all these
airbnbs and apartments and stuff
and i was still like friends with them
and hanging around them but no one
really like
knew what was under the scenes how much
work it took yeah i had no
accountability for
accountability friends yeah i had no one
like
trying to on the same mission as me
why do you think that's dangerous to be
in that situation yeah that's very
dangerous because your environment is
much stronger than your willpower yeah
and that made me to procrastinate a lot
sometimes
and i made a lot of mistakes i learned
from their mistakes and
yeah what do you mean what do you mean
by your environment is stronger than
your willpower
like if even if you want if you say you
want to
make something of yourself if you're in
an environment where everyone's
not doing anything yeah it's it's like
it's almost i don't know why
but it's just how it is and it's just
almost like the environment is too
strong to like
it's like peer pressure almost yeah it's
like if you're around people and they're
doing something
and they and they want you to do it as
well nine times out of ten you're going
to do it even if you don't want to do it
you want the partner you want to be
pressured into success
yeah exactly and that's i think why
because we weren't running discovery
days at the time
sorry we weren't running crash courses
at the time because physical crash
courses because of lockdown but we
started running discovery days
which was like much smaller people six
people
um you booked on one of those yeah so
what happened was
um so i was in that time i was like in a
bit of a depression as well
not really knowing what to do and then i
was just scrolling through
and i saw i saw that um the ad for the
it was the very first one the discovery
day and i was like
whoa i was like oh is that it's a samuel
guy oh that's basically how i started my
journey
i was like oh he's asking people to come
to his house i was like
people must be jumping straight on this
so within a split second i just
went straight on it signed up for it and
then i came over here
and then obviously it was a great day we
learned we learned a
whole lot through the day all through
the day packed with value
um but one main thing was
when i was here for the first time in a
long a very long time
i was around like other people on the
same mission
or high energy or good energy meeting
you in the flesh
like it's something completely different
to even online like online's one thing
watching youtube videos and that
but being here being around you and your
friends seeing your family and everyone
and how everyone was happy and like well
connected
like that's something that like properly
motivated me and
like the house is one thing and
obviously it's a
beautiful house and i love to live
somewhere like this one day
but just to see how everyone was all
happy and
connected here yeah that's like that
inspired me
and i knew i had to like get out of what
whatever phase i was in and just
get around people like yourselves yeah
so i went back
um and i bought the deal selling course
which was amazing as well bought the
deal selling course after the day
uh went back i started smashing that
shortly after
the eviction was announced um jumped
straight on that
i didn't know i was going to get um
picked i had no
idea but i got straight on that uh send
the email
did the interview with emilia amazing
person
um and then when it came to the day when
you were picking
i remember um i was just sat in my room
i was meant to go for a meal
and i was actually running late so i was
like that's like so i just leave it
cause i'm probably not gonna get picked
anyway because i've never been like
chosen for anything i've never won
anything
um so i watched and then the first he
said the first name
and i was like okay well done to them
second name
and it was taking quite long because you
were wanting to
first you had to find them they
confirmed it was them then you called
them to get their reaction and stuff
yeah
and then you're like all right guys it's
taking quite long now so i'm just gonna
bang out a few names
and i was like wait a minute he might
say my name like now
if he's going to bang out of you might
as well just wait and see there's
hundreds of people on this yeah yeah
yeah
so when you said that i was actually
about when you was going
one like for the first and second and
third
i was about to just leave it and then
you said all right now i'm gonna bang
out a few and i was like oh i might as
well stay then
because i was actually running late as
well and then i was like okay then so
then you said the first name said the
second name
and then he said my name you pronounced
it a bit wrong so i was like
is it me is it not me jamel robinson
yeah jamal robinson how did i
said jamel robinson's so i was like oh
goblin
yeah so i was like he's just a different
guy yeah yeah so i was typing in the
chat i was like is me and then
everyone was like yeah excuse you so i
was over the moon i was gasped i was
jumping about and stuff even my mom was
like what's going on i was going
upstairs i told her i was happy then i
went out to that meal
and it was basically like a celebration
celebrated that night
it was great and then i was still
smashing the
deal selling course um and just learning
about that and watching videos about
that
and then obviously the eviction came and
obviously you set us the homework which
was to finish the
bio refurbishing furniture
yeah so um what happened was i was still
like completing the uh the deal selling
course so i was thinking all right then
i'll finish the deal selling course
first um and then i'll just
smash out the brr before we have to come
back so i was doing the deal selling
course
and i was doing viewings because i was
taking action as i was going through it
yeah i found two great deals in
doncaster
i actually sat with the with the vendor
she was a motivated seller as well
uh because of tax complications and
stuff she just wanted to get rid of them
they were turnkey investments they were
great i had no investors so i was
speaking to james armstrong at the time
about him co-sourcing them and then by
the end of the week before i knew it i
had two days left and i was like oh [ __ ]
i need to
get on the br challenge so i went on
that and i was smashing that
and then and then i um and then i
thought you know when we came
uh for the meal yeah i thought okay so
you're looking for the meal
yeah for the meal so i thought okay
um we're gonna go for a meal and it's
gonna start a day later so i've still
got some to finish but i'll just come
for this meal
and then well to be fair you had a lot
more
and then i'll go back to the hotel and
just smash it out for hours
um and then obviously there was an
unexpected turn of events
yeah but that's just how business is
sometimes yeah and that's why i accepted
it
straight away i accepted it and i took
full responsibility
because that's what you have to do yeah
and you were the first person i was like
yeah have you finished the training you
said not
quite finished it and i was like well in
that case yeah you're a victim
get out of here you're fast yeah it was
like
shock we shot it was savage right it was
savage
oh yeah i was shocked i was so shocked
and yeah how can you know i don't know
yeah yeah yeah because because i didn't
see it coming at all but um
yeah i don't really want to accept it as
well yeah i was meant to i was gonna go
home but then i was like
no i'm i was like i'm staying in london
until i find the deal and sell it
because um i knew that the next the next
challenge was to find a deal and sell it
so i was like let me just stay in london
find the deal and sell it and then let
me message samuel i messaged you on that
night as well
yeah and you replied i was like what if
i can find the deal and sell it before
anyone else
will you let me back on i was like
saying stuff like that yeah yeah yeah
you're harassing me
some people when they're evicted will be
like you know you can't evict me i'm
leaving you with the opposite people
i'm not going anywhere yeah
um but i think you know what and you put
a nice comment up on the eviction where
you were like look and you explained
kind of
you took it you took it well i pinned
the comment and even though you were
only featured for
you know a minute or two on the show
you've got a lot of business off the
back of it you've had like
messages and support and love which is
really good
um and you came across well you know and
it was unfortunate that you had to get
evicted
uh so soon but this is this is life
what happened after that then you went
and did a whole bunch of deals which
have resulted in financial freedom for
you since the eviction so yeah yeah so
um
so when i was in london um i was
obviously i was
saying i'm not going home until i find a
deal yeah i actually did find a good
deal but it was quite expensive and i
didn't manage to get any investors for
it
and then i realized let me just go back
to sheffield there's loads of deals
around there
and actually start properly doing this
so i went back to sheffield and i met up
with a friend about it
because i've actually started it with a
friend
so straight away we were just smashing
the smashing the rest of the deal
selling course
and we were just going through it
booking viewings
going on uh days out long days out we
went to
lincoln hall getting investors on the
list
um and that's when i um found the
the new deal that we've got the 11
bedroom hmo that i told you about
yeah so that was actually from another
connection from the estate agent
did you sell that deal no no we took
that deal
oh you took it yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that was a connection from the state
agency because i realized
i've got an estate agency i can utilize
the connections from here
so i was ringing a few and i found out
that one of them was actually
he was renovating a few and i found out
that one of them was actually
he was renovating this massive 11
bedroom hmo
with the two bedroom cottage as well and
he was planning to run out after
so i was thinking okay let's let's have
a look at this and maybe we can do
something with it
so we went there and actually realized
that my dad actually used to rent it
from him about 10 years ago
probably even longer i think i was about
seven eight and he used to use it as a
as a b interesting and then i was and
then
it just brought back memories to me i
was like we have to take this deal yeah
and at first i thought this is a deal i
can sell it i can sell this easily
i can probably make five or even more
grand from this deal
and then i was like now we have to take
it so we sat down and i met with my dad
and the landlord
and we agreed to take that deal for 3500
and we're making about 2 000
profit from that deal nice so that's one
deal
he's making you 2 000 pounds and
you're also living round three in it i
believe yeah yeah oh
yeah so yeah so i'm living there with a
friend yeah um
we could have actually got an extra an
extra 500 pounds
um on top of that but i just decided to
move in there myself
like the landlord for that he actually
owns a furniture shop
a furniture company so he kitted out the
whole place
the whole hmo was all all the beds all
the furniture was already there
so we'd have to buy any of that and it's
all done top standard
and when i went into the cottage like i
loved it and i was like i've just got to
live here man
and i was like i've got to just get into
my own space so i can really now focus
and just push it to new levels
so it's basically a rent-to-rent deal
it's really big
it was immaculate it's making two
thousand pound profit after all costs
and expenses
and you're using it to live in yourself
because it's quite nice yeah
so that's an incredible deal um what
what were the lessons from securing that
deal like someone that's thinking
i wanted to go and secure a deal like
that what would your advice be
yeah so the the advice is just um just
if you if you're a deal sourcer tell the
world tell the world you're looking for
deals tell everyone you know
and that's what i was doing i was
utilizing everything i was telling
everyone i know
and when i was gaining investors for my
list as well
i was even thinking about people like um
people like my power team for the
service accommodations like even the
engineers and stuff i was calling them
and it happened that they have
properties and they actually investing
puppies and stuff yeah so it's just
about
telling everyone who you are and that's
actually how we sold our first deal as
well
um but i'll come to that and then
shortly after that i went to the deal
selling master class with alex there you
said did you go to the live you went to
the library yeah okay
yeah that's amazing amazing course i met
some amazing friends from there
uh friends that i'll probably know from
my whole life through my entire journey
yeah
um it's so inspirational like what i've
what i've seen from videos what alastair
began and what he is now yeah
yeah and he's such an amazing basically
i basically um
created that program almost alistair
yeah was saying to me i want to learn
about deals i want to learn about this
then so i put together that program
he was the very first person that went
through that training
and um obviously he's gone on to sell
hundreds and hundreds of deals
so um he's um definitely an
inspirational person so i mean spending
time with people like that and been able
to see exactly how they do it and how it
works
um because once you see someone did he
sell deals in front of you
live oh yeah so yeah i think he managed
to sell the deal as well yeah
when you see that that you can't unsee
it you can't you can't say well you see
when you see
you can't go back to working for a job
for two grand a month yeah
no no not a chance yeah and what
happened is
i learned a lot on the online course but
the dsm also filled in like a few gaps
that i had in my knowledge
yeah so that just like completed the
puzzle for me
yeah um so i went back i had more
friends
just like from the eviction more
lifelong friends more accountability
partners
um went back uh started and as i started
getting investors pretty quickly
for utilization of social media and
stuff the estate agency
and what i did i sorted my website out
sorted the landing page
got compliant everything and we were
finding deals
and we were getting three four five
investors every day onto the list
getting them to fill out the list and
then we were smashing out there
the weekly email yeah but what happened
is we found good deals the first email
um we got no no like callbacks or
anything
so i thought we'll just go again we'll
find
some more great deals we'll go again the
next week
we didn't get anything again and then i
was thinking so what's going wrong i'm
doing everything right
here i've got everything set up and then
and then i realized like obviously
alistair and samuel they can smash out
an email and get a response back
just like that yeah and that's down to
you because
of their reputation they've got trust
yeah they've got a big reputation
and that's exactly why and i was and
then i thought what i need to do is i
need to get trust in my investors i need
to make it a more personal experience
for them
obviously you you've got thousands of
people on your list
so it's obviously harder for you don't
even need to make it
that much of a personal thing but if
you're growing from one investor yeah
yeah sure to ten
you have to have a personal relationship
with their investors you can't just
think oh it's just a number on the list
yeah i'm gonna blast out this and
they're gonna send me three grand
yeah right so that's what i started
doing so every investor now we have
we make sure that me or my business
partner we sit down with them or on the
phone
for like half an hour talk about
everything that what they're interested
in
talk about different strategies maybe
that they're not even aware of
yeah um what they're looking for their
budgets and stuff and then when we find
deals now
we we ring them like ring people that
are suited to that deal and go through
it with them as well
and we just found that that's that works
a lot better yeah they're just thinking
about yourself send out an email saying
deals now yeah yeah so
uh we've only just got over that hurdle
and we sold one deal straight away
basically right
and that was from someone that referred
me to this landlord
and when i i rang him turns out he's
he owns over 100 properties around south
yorkshire
and then he was just like oh i'm just
looking for a cheap buy to let's
um and stuff like that as i talked to
him for about half an hour about what
he's doing
i even spoke about how did he how did he
even get that they're the best
how did he get yeah i was talking about
how did he get to that level and stuff
like that
um and then we actually found one in
rotherham it was a
turnkey investment it was on for 60
grand we managed to negotiate it for 54
and he was happy with that and we took a
two grand fee and that was literally
about a week or so ago
and that was the first one and then yeah
and
and that's when i just realized like
it's starting to work and we've got the
system in
place um we value every investor
yeah um and yeah and when that money
hits the bank
that's when you just know there's no
going back it's only forward from here
and when you've got a rent to rent
that's making you 2 pounds a month
you're living rent free
if you're just able to sell one deal a
month on top of that and top yeah
yeah i mean i mean suddenly it becomes a
really good income
yeah yeah of course so um so i mean and
living rent free is always always a good
thing as well yeah what would be advised
into someone starting out
so someone starting out is just just add
as much value as you can
just learn as much as you can and um
definitely
definitely take the training because
you'll avoid a lot of costly mistakes
you'll avoid wasting a lot of time as
well and
the training is something that's got me
where i am today yeah i had a lot of
leverage
from my dad's experience and his
connections and stuff but
if it wasn't for the training and stuff
right now i could be still in the estate
agency making 200 pounds a week
yeah so yeah that's it um so definitely
if you're looking to get started you
should definitely invest in training
invest in yourself and just look to add
as much value as you can
yeah yeah now that's really good and
honestly you know it's been great
working with you over the last
few few weeks and months um because
you've got you know you've got integrity
you're somebody that works really hard
to get the best deals
so um i wish you all the best in your in
your deal sourcing and deal selling side
of things as well if someone wants to
reach out to you or if they want to
um find you know have a look at the
deals you've got available how what
would the best way to do that
yeah so um i've got a link for
all that stuff i'm sure we can put in
what's your website you know stuff
so it's called win more investments when
moreinvestments.com
yeah i'll put it in the description
brother and description and um
yeah and on the deals um there's
sa side of things we've actually got
four more as well that we've secured oh
nice so we've got four more that was
secured they're under refurbishment
they're at 650 each so you'll rent their
rent to rent
yeah and how much are they going to be
so they're going to be 650 each
no we're going to be looking to make
about 500 pound profit okay cool being
realistic
yeah they're under refurbishment right
now so when we take that on
that's an extra 2 000 profit per month
yeah and then
we're also we've got lined up eight
studio apartments as well in the city
center to have a look at
so by summer once everything's smoothed
out and stuff if everything goes well
with chronovirus
we're looking to have like around around
22 to 24 units in total
no we'll have stuff in there they're in
place to make it fully systemized yeah
and then i'll be fully focusing on the
deal selling business
and we hope to be selling two to four
deals per month by then as well
that's great and then by that time maybe
by the end of the year
we'll get our part two yeah we'll get a
part two and you guys are
financially free to ultimately
financially then we'll do a part three
which is you're a millionaire yeah in a
couple years time hopefully
yeah yeah speaking of millionaires
watching the
um the final of the eviction and i was
with my friend armstrong
and he messaged you as well that night
we were sat down watching it
and literally you know the end the end
announcement when you did the
millionaire announcement literally just
sent a shiver down my spine like
wow that's so amazing yeah i was so
happy for lauren and the guys
i haven't met a lot on the other day and
we're going to be doing some deals
together as well that's great um
i was just so happy for them and i'm
actually so thankful that you're
actually providing these opportunities
for people
and if it wasn't for you building this
community and stuff
there's so many people that like god
knows where they would have been right
now
and it's it's it's amazing because
that's what it is it is a community
yeah yeah it's um you know we put on a
lot of free training and youtube and
stuff like that which is which is
awesome in books
but the um the advanced training you
know and and
the crash course even like that's where
it starts yeah
what did you think when you first think
about the crash course like what was
your experience yeah so
the first time at the crash course
obviously i rocked up in a suit and
everything was my first time at like a
networking event so i just thought
obviously i was just there
um i thought what can i learn from this
i the energy was crazy i just loved it
um i love the fact that you get everyone
to interact with each other it's not
just like everyone there just sitting
watching someone teach
everyone has to interact do deals find
deals together and stuff like that
and i just thought it was amazing i just
couldn't believe that it was basically
for free
yeah yeah that's the only thing like and
we're doing a virtual crash courses now
online as well the virtual questions i
think did you come to one of them yeah
yeah yeah so i came to that for a bit i
didn't manage to stay for the whole
generation
but i checked out that was it like and
that one is is just as value-packed
and obviously people have to do it from
home now and yeah
and it's not the physical one but you
learn the same stuff
yeah if you take action you're gonna get
the same results
yeah well dude i'm super proud of what
you've done i can't wait to see you
i can't thank you enough man nah dude
you're so welcome so uh thanks for
coming on the show
guys i think you'll agree jamal's an
awesome guy drop a nice comment
um below for jamal check him out find
him and
and hopefully you'll be able to do some
business with him as well if you enjoyed
the interview
uh do me a favor smash the like button
subscribe to the channel also
i do this every single week we do an
interview with one of the success
students
so if you want to see a whole playlist
of over 100 interviews just like this
check out the playlist right here and
i'll look forward to seeing you real
real soon thanks god bless
[Music]
you